it's always exciting to think about what
kinds of technology are going to be
coming to us in the future by
extrapolating from current trends we can
make some good guesses about some of the
astonishing inventions that are going to
be around 30 or 50 years from now yet
when we imagine the technology of the
future too often we restrict our
imaginations to particular areas we
think a lot about what's going to happen
around things like high-speed air travel
space exploration energy generation
telecommunications and warfare but the
potential of technology is in truth
going to be far broader than this in the
future technology will first and
foremost develop to help us deal more
successfully with our emotional lives
thanks to advances in artificial
intelligence robotics and nano
engineering we predict we're going to
see an explosion in what we like to call
emotional technology here are our
predictions about four inventions we
feel sure will exist in half a century
or so especially if we talk enough about
them today one of the major sources of
conflict and grief between people
especially in relationships stems from
how bad we are at explaining the
contents of our minds to other people in
short we're appalling communicators we
grunt we can't find the words we bottle
up feelings we don't know what's going
on inside us and therefore can't signal
our needs to others when we're on the
receiving end of inaccurately
communicated feelings we tend to make
bad guesses about what might be going on
in the other person we get overly
alarmed we come up with jumpy ungenerous
stories our guesses make things far
worse than they usually need to be just
as we invented the wheel because our
legs were imperfect in the bucket
because our fingers couldn't carry water
so we will invent the mood reader to
counteract some of our natural
weaknesses around interpreting others
the mood reader will be able to give
people close to us whom we elect
beautifully expressed executive
summaries of what we're really feeling
at a given point laid out in ways that
are accurate generous and imaginative
like something a great novelist would
come
up with when you come home from work and
don't have the energy or insight to say
what's on your mind the mood reader will
take care of it it will explain that
you're not angry you're just exhausted
or at a party when you flirt with a
person the mood reader will explain that
it's not that you don't love your
partner anymore
it's just that occasionally you need to
know you can still attract it might have
looked like a horrid betrayal yet really
was simply just a bit of meaningless fun
currently too often a person in a couple
will say in despair after a long silent
how did you expect me to be a mind
reader well technology will spare us the
cumulative years of sulks and arguments
by allowing us to be for a time just
that in the future we'll look back in
horror at the primitive dating websites
of today the spouse finder of 2050 will
be an expert of finding you a match
partly because everyone on the planet
will be registered with it but just as
importantly because it will have such an
acute understanding of our deepest needs
and emotional vulnerabilities even those
we don't quite understand ourselves or
are not good at acknowledging the spouse
finder will have a picture of our
long-term development in its memory it
will for example know that we might need
someone who can occasionally stand up to
us though will do so kindly and not
break us as they do so the spouse finder
won't be driven by an illusory goal of
mutual bliss or trouble-free love it
will know that all relationships have
areas of deep compromise but it will try
to direct us towards the best available
fit given our nature and that of the
rest of the human race the spouse finder
will know us and others so well it'll
have the authority to convince us when
we do hit tricky patches with a partner
it's found us but for all its faults our
relationship really is the best
available for us it'll give us the
confidence to believe that the
trickiness of our couple emerges not so
much from the other person as from the
inherent difficulty of being with anyone
the couple finder will put a lid on the
persistent idea currently responsible
for so
tragically broken homes that we could be
happy if we just went off with someone
else who looks pretty nice on their
profile photo named after the world's
greatest early philosopher Socrates who
famously said that the first
philosophical priority is to know
yourself Socrates would be a piece of
wearable emotional technology that will
make up for our failures of
self-knowledge in real time we imagine
it as a kind of wearable life coach with
a total understanding of our mental
health who we are and what we need to
thrive emotionally at key moments
Socrates will be on hand to temper our
excesses and correct our emotional blind
spots it will know when we're getting to
an angry outburst and counsel us wisely
before it's too late it will sense
mounting panic and be on hand
immediately with the most soothing
insights humanity has ever had it'll
wean us away from unhelpful desires and
compulsions towards more fruitful and
enriching pursuits it'll know when we
need an extra challenge it will ensure
that we can at all times be the best
version of ourselves we have so much
that's precious clever and creative
inside of us but rarely do we have the
insight and opportunity to externalize
our talents and put them to productive
use in the economy what's on our
business card seldom reflects our
deepest possibilities the career locator
will understand our true potential and
have the ability to mine it while
there's still time bringing it to the
surface and matching it to the
requirements of the economy it will
tease out the latent talent or genius
that exists in all of us
it will know before we do where our true
destiny lies it will know how we measure
up to others and what our chances of
success in a given field really are it
will once and for all do away with a
terrible panic and sadness we tend to
feel often on Sunday evenings as we
realize that we're heading to the grave
with the most precious parts of us still
unexploited the promise of technology
has always been that it will make life
more convenient and less painful but to
date we haven't managed to focus on
technological efforts on the biggest
sources of
content which are to do with the size of
our phones or the speed of our planes
but with our emotional lives and the
turmoil caused in them by our self
ignorance cognitive frailty and inner
blindness that is the astonishing
promise of the upcoming age of emotional
technology
you